PROFESSOR: I want to demonstrate
two ways in which you
can see phase shift.
So basically, the reason
we use phase shift
is that these are the things
that you can calculate.
Calculating phase
shifts is possible.
So how do you do that?
We'll be a two-step procedure.
We'll only finish
that next time.
But let's get started.
So suppose you have
your wave again.
And for a fixed l, a
given partial wave,
this is the full solution
for this scattering problem.
It is an Al Jl of kr
plus bl at Nl of kr.
y l0.
That's your solution.
The signal that
you got scattering,
and you have
something right here,
is the existence of this
term, because when there's
no potential and no
scattering, the solution
is valid all the
way to r equals 0,
and therefore, this
has no singularity.
But this term is saying
that this solution
doesn't extend all
the way to r equals 0,
because this diverges.
So something un-trivial
is happening.
So bl is the signal
that they're scattering.
Now, expand for large R. So this
is proportional to Al sine kr
minus l pi over 2 minus bl
cosine kr minus l pi over 2
y l0 1 over a kr.
It's the same.
I'm going to drop all
constants very fast.
Now, here is my claim.
You were thinking
of phase shifts.
Well, the phase shift is
nothing else than bl over Al
is minus the tangent
of the phase shift.
This is a claim.
Or you could say this is another
definition of a phase shift,
and I'm going to argue that it's
the same, actually, than what
we did.
To do that, I have to
just expand a little more.
So what I'm going to
do is divide by a,
so take the a out, akr.
Now you have sine kr minus l
pi over 2 minus bl over Al.
Bl over Al is tangent
delta, so plus tan delta l
cosine kr minus
l pi over 2 y l0.
And that is proportional to
a over kr tangent delta l
is sine over cosine.
So let's put the 1
over cosine delta l
here, sine kr minus l
pi over 2 cosine delta l
plus cosine kr minus l pi over
2 sine delta l y l0 of theta.
So that ratio tangent, I
put a sine over cosine,
I have it here.
But this, your favorite
trigonometric identity,
is equal to a over kr
1 over cosine delta l
sine, a single sine of kr
minus l pi over 2 plus delta l.
So if this is the phase
shift, the solution
looks like this far away, a
sine of kr minus l pi over 2,
plus a delta l.
That's one way of
identifying the phase shift.
But I want to show that's the
same phase shift we had before,
but that's clear already.
Up to constants, this is--
I'm sorry, y l0 of theta.
And up to constants, this is e
to the ik r minus l pi over 2
plus i delta minus
e to the i minus ik
r minus l pi over
2 minus i delta.
And now I drop everything else.
And now I multiply or take
out this phase, take it out.
I'm just working up to
proportionality, which
is all you care at this moment.
And this is e to the i
kr minus l pi over 2.
If I take that out, this
becomes plus 2i delta l.
And this becomes minus e to the
minus i kr minus l pi over 2.
And those are the waves we had
before, somewhere here, here.
Here they are.
You see them?
Still, they were here.
This wave and that wave with
delta here has showed up.
So this delta that
I've defined here
is the same phase shift
we introduced before.
So now you have three ways
of recognizing a phase shift.
A phase shift can be recognized
in the partial wave expansion.
A phase shift can be
recognized by looking
at the scattering wave
far away and seeing
that it takes this
form, and you say,
oh, here is the phase shift.
And the phase shift
can be recognized
by looking at the solution
in terms of spherical Bessel
functions, and it's the
ratio of these coefficients.
Those are the three definitions
of the phase shift, three ways
of seeing your phase shift.
Instead of elaborating
more on this,
let's do one example
to convince you
that this is solvable
and doable in fact.
So the example is a
hard sphere example.
This is the object that
you're scattering off.
The potential is equal to
infinity for r less than a
and 0 for r greater than a.
This is the origin and radius
a sphere, the waves come in.
You want the cross-section.
OK.
It might look like
this is hard, OK.
How are we ever
going to solve this?
In fact, will be very easy.
We have everything
ready to solve.
So let's remember what we have.
Well, there's going to
be a radial solution,
Rl Remember Rl is Ul over
R. And that takes the form
Al Jl of kr plus Bl Nl of kr.
That is the general
solution for a radial thing,
and therefore your general
solution for your wave function
or of theta is what
we were writing here,
except that the
superposition of them.
So I said here is
how you recognize
what is the phase shift
for a given partial wave,
but we're going to have
all the partial wave.
So this is going to
be the sum over l
of these things, Al
of Jl of kr plus Bl
Nl of kr times Pl of theta.
I could write y l0, but
that's up to a constant Pl.
So that's your general solution.
And in fact, I didn't
even have to write this,
because you have there on
that blackboard, that's
the general solution for the
full wave away from this sphere
that's not valid
for R less than 0.
But this is your full solution
for a given partial wave
for all the waves it's there.
OK, so that equation
solves a problem.
pl of cosine theta, yes.
It's really better
written like that.
Yes, that's more rigorous.
Yes.
OK, so what do we do now?
Somehow you have to use it.
You have a sphere.
We haven't used a sphere yet.
So what does the
sphere tell you?
It tells you that
the wave function
must vanish on the sphere,
because it's infinitely hard.
It's like an infinite wall.
So this wave function
should vanish psi
at a theta, which
is equal to sum over
l Al Jl of ka plus Bl of Nl
of ka times Pl of cosine theta
should be 0.
OK.
One equation for
infinitely many unknowns,
but the Pl's are a complete set.
If you expand the function of
theta in terms of Pl's, you
can determine every coefficient.
They're linearly
independent, the Pl's.
So if you can think
of this, this is an a.
This is just a number.
So this is a sum of numbers
times Pl's must be 0.
All the numbers must
be 0, because the Pl's
are independent.
Therefore, here we have that
a Al Jl of ka plus Bl Nl of ka
must be 0 for all l.
And therefore, tangent delta
l, which is minus Bl over Al
has been determined.
The tangent delta l is Bl
over Al, and that's equal to--
it's Jl of ka over Nl of ka.
Done.
All phase shifts computed.
The Bessel functions are known.
You look them up.
You calculate them
to any accuracy.
But you have here
all the phase shifts.
Therefore, you have the
cross section of this sphere.
You have the differential
cross section.
You have anything you want.
It has all been determined.
We can do a little
bit of algebra
if you want to calculate
what the sine squared
delta of something.
Sine squared can be expressed
in terms of tan squared.
It's tan squared delta l over
1 plus tan squared delta l.
So it's our Jl squared over
Jl squared plus Nl squared.
Tan l, you substitute
this, and you get that.
Therefore, the cross
section can be calculated,
and the differential cross
section can be calculated.
It's pretty interesting.
Let's do it here.
The cross section, remember
sigma is 4 pi over k,
sum over l equals 0 to
infinity 2l plus 1 times
this sine squared.
So Jl of ka squared over
Jl squared of ka plus Nl
squared of ka.
So that's your
full cross section.
If k is very small, ka much
less than 1, that's small k.
That's small energy, long
wavelength approximation.
This formula is interesting for
high energy, for low energy,
for intermediate energies.
The angular dependence
is interesting.
It's a lots of things
you could look at.
Let's look at low energy.
You need the expansions of this
quantities for small things,
and they're easy to find.
Basically, this remain finite.
This becomes infinite.
It dominates it.
It's not difficult.
I'll write what 1 gets.
It's 4 pi over k
squared, sum over l
equals 0 to infinity,
1 over 2 l plus 1 2
to the l l factorial
2l factorial.
So a mess of factorials.
I'm sorry.
ka to the 4l plus 2.
And here is to the
question of convergence
if ka is much smaller
than 1, in this case--
this was the approximation--
that will sure converge.
The powers go up and up.
So for l equals 0,
it is interesting,
is the dominant one.
So l equals 0 only sigma turns
out to be 4 pi over k squared.
And all these factors just
give you a 1 for l equals 0.
The ka squared, a
squared, ka squared,
which is 4 pi a squared,
which is a pretty cute answer.
This is the low
frequency cross section.
If it's a long wave
length approximation,
the cross section of the object
is not the apparent cross
section, which is the diameter,
but it's actually the full area
of the sphere 4 pi a squared.
People try to
imagine why this is.
It's almost like the
wavelength is so big
that the wave wraps around the
sphere and gets stuck there.
So the sphere captures
proportional to the area
of the whole thing.
So we'll see more
of that next time.